bonjour la jordanie avec aujourd'hui
trois questions principales
tout d'abord la situation sur le terrain
et là il semble qu'au cours de ces
dernières heures le roi hussein et son
armée et marquer quelques points
deuxièmement les chances d'un accord
d'un compromis d'un cessez le feu entre
les troupes du roi hussein et les
palestiniens
là il semble que ces champs soient
toujours aussi mince pour ne pas dire
inexistantes
enfin les risques d'une intervention
étrangère en jordanie
tout d'abord si vous le voulez bien sur
une carte la situation sur le terrain
tout d'abord à man à amman on se bat
encore les palestiniens des poches de
résistance et cette nuit encore de
violents combats des tirs d'artillerie
des tirs de mortier dans le nord du pays
voyait des parties grise et aux prêts de
ramtha dire beard de j'arrache de soldes
toute évidence ce sont là des bases que
les palestiniens tiennent et tiennent
solidement appuyée par les éléments de
l'armée syrienne
depuis hier l'armée jordanienne a lancé
contre ces bases palestiniennes des
offensives qui sont symbolisés sur cette
carte par des flèches
or et c'est là le fait nouveau il semble
que ces offensives et donner certains
résultats et que les jordaniens et 1
infligé aux palestiniens et aux syriens
des pertes sévères
quoi qu'il en soit ce matin aucun
problème les palestiniens tiennent
toujours ces régions et l'on se bat avec
beaucoup de violence
aux dernières nouvelles on apprenait
même que l'aviation jordanienne avait
commencé le bombardement d'hier bide
et puis un autre fait nouveau mais qui
cette fois concerne le sud du pays alors
que l'on croyait ce sud du pays
entièrement contrôlée par les jordaniens
des journalistes qui circulaient dans le
sud de la jordanie en direction de
l'arabie saoudite et donc du golfe
d'aqaba ont été arrêtés et contrôlés par
les commandos palestiniens il semble
donc que les palestiniens se soit
également infiltré et installé des
postes de résistance dans le sud du pays
deuxième point les tentatives de
solution politique est là on est
vraiment au point mort calais hier la
réunion de la ligue arabe au caire n'a
pratiquement rien donné bien que ce soit
prolongée jusqu'à une heure du matin
elle a conclu par l'envoi d'une mission
de conciliation à amman une mission de
conciliation dont on voit mal dans
l'état actuel des choses ce qu'elle
pourrait il reste que ce matin le roi
hussein a annoncé la libération de
quatre dirigeants palestiniens arrêtés
il y a quelques jours et le roi hussein
a dit j'ai conclu avec ses quatre
dirigeants anac
qui doit permettre le cce mais il est
évident que cet accord conclu avec ses
dirigeants arrêtés et qui donne entière
satisfaction aux thèses du roi hussein
est pratiquement inacceptable pour les
autres dirigeants palestiniens dès ce
matin la direction des palestiniennes le
commandement palestinien annoncé nous
poursuivons la lutte
et nous la poursuivrons jusqu'où semble
bien que l'annoncé par le roi hussein la
libération de quatre dirigeants
palestiniens arrêtés et l'annoncé cet
accord est en fait une manoeuvre de
guerre psychologique qui ne donnera
aucun résultat concret reste alors la
question d'une éventuelle intervention
étrangère qui serait peut-être
américaines ou israéliennes une chose à
noter ce matin le gouvernement turc a
formellement démenti des informations
selon lesquelles des avions américains
se seraient posés cette nuit sur la base
autant de turquie la base d'adana les
tirs que disent ces faux aucun renfort
america est arrivé cette nuit en turc
il n'en reste pas moins stéphane paoli
que du côté anglais comme du côté
américain on se prépare à faire face à
toute éventualité
depuis hier matin trois bataillons et
reporter américain ainsi qu'une
compagnie de commandement formant une
brigade d'environ 3000 hommes se
trouvent en état d' alerte rouge dans la
région de bad creuse n'a qu en allemagne
de l'ouest
ce matin alain cances vous l'a dit
plusieurs agences de presse avaient même
annoncé que 18 appareils américains
transport de la base aérienne de rain
man avait décollé en direction du proche
orient mais vous le savez démenti formel
quoi qu'il en soit l'activité est
intense sur les bases américaines de la
république fédérale allemande
les hommes de troupes ont été vaccinées
le matériel armements lourds et légers a
été embarqué pendant toute la journée
d'hier à bord des avions cargo
même processus sur les bases
britanniques a chip les hercules de la
royal air force se tiennent prêts à
décoller l'ambassadeur de
grande-bretagne monsieur john phillips a
pris les mesures nécessaires pour
l'évacuation rapide si possible
aujourd'hui des femmes et les enfants
des ressortissants britanniques résidant
tam car tant du côté britannique que
chez les américains toute intervention
ne serait limitée pour l'instant qu'à
l'évacuation des ressortissants des deux
nationalités qui vivent en jordanie
il n'empêche que l'on peut se poser les
questions puis officiellement il s'agit
pour les américains comme pour les
anglais d'être prêts à évacuer en cas de
besoin leurs ressortissants qui se
trouvent actuellement en jordanie mais
en ce moment même où anouk washington le
président nixon réuni le conseil de
sécurité des états unis et il est bien
évident que pour les états unis il est
difficilement acceptable d'admettre une
éventuelle chute du roi hussein car le
roi hussein est l'un des chefs d'état
arabes qui l'aurait relativement
favorable de même il est extrêmement
difficile pour les israéliens d'admettre
qu'éventuellement puisse se créer à leur
frontière un état palestinien qui serait
entièrement tourné vers une guerre de
reconquête d'israël c'est pourquoi et
compte tenu de l'évolution sur le
terrain dans les heures qui viennent un
peu partout dans le monde on se demande
ce qui va maintenant se passer surtout
si les palestiniens marquer des points
est menacée très sérieusement le trône
du roi hussein le pape paul 6 à
d'ailleurs évoqué ce matin
ce problème du moyen-orient il a renoncé
à prendre la parole comme il le fait
depuis chaque semaine du haut de son
balcon et il a dit la situation au
moyen-orient nous semble si grave si
menaçante qu'elle ne permettrait pas de
parler d'autres sujets avec un coeur
tranquille et le pape paul vi a lancé un
appel pour éviter que n'arrivent les
choses horribles
c'est également cette situation au moyen
orient qui a été l'un des points
essentiels
ordre du jour du conseil des ministres
français qui s'est réuni ce matin à
l'elysée sous la présidence du président
pompidou
ce conseil est maintenant terminée ne
vont pas encore les résultats exacts
mais nous savons que le gouvernement
français réaffirmera la position déjà
rendues publiques lundi par la
présidence de la république à savoir que
le pendant français est opposée à toute
intervention qu'il pourrait selon lui
qui ne pourraient selon lui qu aggraver
encore la situation ante marche de la
politique française proprement dit
un mini attentats s'est tenu à paris
trois cocktails molotov lancés contre le
célèbre restaurant ledoyen trois
cocktails molotov à un début incendie
vite arrêté et quelques vitres brisées
sur place un tract signé le groupe g
star numéro 3 j'espère je vous le
rappelle l'un des patrons actuellement
emprisonné des groupes maoïstes d'autres
incidences ethnique une variante
politique auprès du palais des sports où
chanter les rolling stones
quelques dizaines de jeunes gens voulu
rentrer sans payer qui se sont heurtés
aux forces de police d'ailleurs très
nombreuses et puis quelques bousculades
également à la sortie en tout cas le
couple de jeunes gens et ces mêmes
forces de police meriane très grave
beaucoup plus grave en revanche ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit sur l'autoroute
de l'estérel jeune homme interpellé par
une patrouille de gendarmerie un coup de
feu part le jeune homme est tué les
gendarmes affirme c'est un accident le
jeune homme a voulu détourner le
revolver braqué sur lui et
malheureusement le coup est parti
mais les parents du jeune homme ne sont
pas satisfaits cette explication ils
veulent porter plainte qui se demandent
notamment pourquoi on a mis dix heures
pour les prévenir de ce drame
paris est de plus en plus paralysé une
constatation que chacun d'entre nous
quand il vient dans la capitale quand il
y habite peut faire chaque jour et c'est
une situation qui risque fort de
s'aggraver puisque les parisiens
utilisent de plus en plus leurs
véhicules personnels à quatre ou à deux
roues est de moins en moins les
transports en commun c'est ainsi qu'hier
monsieur maurice doublet qui le préfet
de la région parisienne a publié des
chiffres des chiffres inquiétants sur
les 12 millions 200 mille déplacement
que les parisiens effectuent chaque jour
53 8% sont maintenant effectuer avec des
moyens de transport individuels et
l'utilisation de ce moyen de transport
individuel est en progression constante
alors paris va vers la paralysie et donc
monsieur maurice doublet propose des
remèdes et remettront ça corner qui ne
sont pas tellement agréable oui
effectivement et comme vous ne l'ignorez
pas un cancer est rouvert à stationner à
cette heure-ci aux champs elysées ce
n'est pas chose facile pour ne pas dire
impossible
j'espère que les policiers ne nous
n'oserons pas de problème pour
retransmettre ce reportage nous nous
sommes garés ici au milieu de l'avenue
nous ne sommes d'ailleurs pas les seuls
à être en stationnement il ici de façon
permanente cent mille voitures
stationnent en infraction dans paris
mais là présent rapport de la préfecture
de la région parisienne
ce ne sont pas les véhicules des
parisiens qui encombrent la capitale
mais ceux des banlieusards en effet plus
de la moitié des 12 millions 200 mille
déplacements quotidiens des habitants
des huit départements de la région
parisienne vers la capitale s'effectue
grâce un transport individuel voiture
comme vous l'avez dit ou deux roues et
c'est assez alarmant effectivement quand
on pense que le parc des voitures
augmente de 6% par an et qu'il doublera
d'ici à 1985
je suis actuellement avec maurice cazaux
qui est spécialiste des questions
routière à france soir maurice cazaux le
préfet de la région parisienne a
préconisé un certain nombre de solutions
décentralisée paris en banlieue instauré
le stationnement paris de payants dans
paris ou à longer les couloirs réservés
aux autobus personnellement qu'en pensez
vous mais je pense que de toute façon
lorsque le préfet dit que si on ne fait
rien maintenant ça va être la
catastrophe bien d'où il a tout à fait
raison
alors les cinq mesures qu'il a
préconisées ce sont vous avez parlé des
100 km de couloirs d'autobus
indispensable pour que les autobus aille
plus vite et qu'on les prenne ensuite
augmentation du confort des transports
en commun et surtout du métro pour
qu'ils aient plus de capacité et qu'on
les envie lui aussi de le prendre
troisièmement diminuer si possible le
nombre de places de parking qui sont
construites auprès des bureaux neufs à
paris et qui appelle des voitures
nouvelle pour eux quatrièmes mans il
s'agit de répartir équitablement entre
la route et le rail
les crédits du sixième plan c'est à dire
55% pour des autoroutes nouvelle et 45%
pour des moyens de transport nouveau et
puis enfin le stationnement payant alors
le stationnement payant bien sûr ça ne
fait pas sourire mais il s'agit de
savoir si oui ou non cette utile de
voiliers or le préfet doublet estime que
en réservant musulmans aux gens qui se
servent de leur voiture pour travailler
à paris les rares places de
stationnement i hear en service dans
l'ensemble à la circulation générale et
y compris à celle de banlieue mais
pensez vous qu'il sera adopté cette
solution
il dépendra du conseil de paris qui va
être élu au mois de mars 1971 de voter
là dessus il avait refusé jusqu'ici
peut-être maintenant écoutera-t-il le
préfet doublet et ce serait de quel
ordre en principe combien payerait dons
pour
passionné une journée dans paris on a
toujours si vous voulez parler d'un
tarif pas et le préfet double estimé qu'
on devrait pouvoir mais il ne tient pas
ce qu'on stationnent toute la journée
d'ailleurs mais il tient à ce qu on
puisse stationner dans des parkings
périphériques pour trois francs à 4
francs par jour pas plus eh bien vous
voyez alain quand c'est si cette loi est
votée ce n'est pas très réjouissant pour
les automobilistes devront l'antenne
avocats n'y a que j'ai demandé s'il
n'était pas l'humoriste alphonse allais
qui avait raison quand il proposait de
mettre les villes à la campagne
d'ailleurs la circulation n'est pas le
seul problème qui se pose aux grandes
villes il y à tous les problèmes de
pollution et la vie dans ces grandes
villes devient de plus en plus difficile
on vous en parle beaucoup mais voyons
maintenant avec emmanuel de la taille
comment réagissent les habitants des
grandes villes américaines
déclin et appauvrissement les villes
géantes ruée vers l'ouest
les premiers résultats du recensement
qui sortent des ordinateurs
modifie profondément le visage des états
ou premier phénomène
le déclin des grandes villes new york
reste bien la ville numéro un des états
unis avec 7 millions 700 mille habitants
mais depuis dix ans la population
minorque à stagner voire régresser
puisque new york aurait même perdu dix
mille habitants le phénomène est général
la moitié des 25 plus grandes villes
américaines ont vu leur population
décroître c'est le cas en particulier de
quatre des cinq premières new york
chicago philadelphie des trois seuls los
angeles cette super banlieue a vu sa
population augmente deuxième phénomène
la ruée vers l'ouest la fantastique
expansion de la côte ouest pacifique des
états unis aux dépens de la côte est
le président nixon ne s'y est pas trompé
politiquement en installant sa seconde
maison blanche en californie c'est
maintenant la californie qui vient en
état numéro 1 avec 20 millions aux états
unis devançant pour la première fois
l'état de new york qui sera même
vraisemblablement obligé de lui céder
deux sièges de députés
troisième phénomène l'appauvrissement ce
sont les classes pauvres les noirs qui
ont tendance à venir dans les grandes
villes prendre le relais des classes
riches doyenne qui préfèrent la banlieue
voire la campagne les raisons qui
poussent les hits ada à fuir ces super
villes dont new york et apple symboles
sont évidents
oppression congestion bousculade
il faut faire la queue partout là que
pour venir le matin pour prendre le bus
pour déposer vous retirer sa voiture
dans les parkings même pour manger
pollution d'audi les ordures qui ne sont
pas ramassées la grande ville et ses
mots sont bien connus malheureusement la
fuite des citadins hors de ces grandes
villes aggrave encore leurs problèmes en
effet d'un côté il faut de plus en plus
d'argent pour lutter contre les taudis
contre la pollution améliorer les
équipements publics et de l'autre les
grandes villes ont de moins en moins de
ressources
en effet d'un côté la population est
plus pauvres et paie donc moins d'impôts
et d'autre part si la population diminue
les subventions d'état diminue dans la
même proportion
du coup le maire de new york monsieur
john lindsay bas maintenant le rappel de
la population pour que ceux qui ne sont
pas encore inscrits dans le recensement
aille très vite
signé sur les registres de façon à ce
que ces subventions de diminue ceux-ci
manifeste de la gravité des problèmes
qu'affronte nous y sommes en tout cas
une chose est certaine un des seuls
domaines où new york a battu tous les
records de croissance c'est celui de la
hausse des prix un des nombreux sujets
de mécontentement pour les 7 millions
700 mille new york est jusqu'ici recense
depuis samedi une réserve de gaz
brûlants bavière et une réserve de gaz
peu banal puisque situé à 700 m sous
terre elle ne contient pas moins de 170
millions de mètres cubes un chiffre
fantastique pour essayer d'éteindre cet
incendie
les propriétaires de la firme à laquelle
à partir des réserves de gaz ont décidé
de faire appel à red adair celui que
l'on appelle le pompier volant l'homme
qui se fait fort d'éteindre n'importe
quel instant dit michel toulouse oui
sous cette clairière en bavière à 700
mètres de profondeur 170 millions de
mètres cubes de gaz naturel à la suite
d'une fausse manoeuvre le gaz s'échappe
à une pression de 40 atmosphère et
s'enflamme au contact de l'air à cette
vitesse il faut des trois ans avant que
la réserve ne soit épuisé
nous voyons ici les 350 pompiers
essayant de noyer le foyer sous des
flots d'eau puisée dans les rivières
avoisinantes et jusque dans une piscine
à trois kilomètres de là on a aussi
commencé à percé un conduit souterrain
pour injecter du ciment rapide afin de
juguler la fuite
mais toutes ces opérations n'ont donné
que très peu de résultats
il ne restait plus alors qu'à faire
appel aux pompiers volant l'américain
red adair 60 ans sa devise un feu un
homme
il doit arriver aujourd'hui avec sa
petite valise bourrée de dynamiter il a
déclaré à son départ de houston que cet
incendie ne lui poserait pas de gros
problèmes je crois que les dirigeants
allemands ont résister si longtemps
avant de faire appel à red adair c'est
que monsieur red adair est un homme qui
a l'habitude de se faire payer très très
très cher françois de closets vous avez
vous rencontré des savants et des
savants siens qui est de leurs
recherches qu'ils veulent les interrompt
pourtant apparemment c'était des savants
bien inoffensifs puisqu'il faisait des
recherches sur la propagation des ondes
acoustiques un sujet 2e de seconde
vous savez il ya depuis 1945 depuis
l'explosion de la première bombe
atomique les savants savent que la
science n'est jamais innocente et en
occurrence ces savants après la bombe
atomique ont formé une sorte
d'internationale de savants qu'on
appelle le mouvement de gauche qui
s'efforce de maintenir la paix ils se
sont réunis ils ont lancé une alarme
justement ce problème de la propagation
raisons d'acoustique
alors pourquoi ce nom pour une raison
très simple vous le savez le radar ne
peut pas fonctionner dans l'eau seuls
les ondes acoustiques permettent
d'utiliser le sonar
sonar et à courte portée ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les sous marins
nucléaires
nous allons voir un exemple sont
invulnérables dans les océans
or distille les recherches actuelles sur
les ondes acoustiques et l'utilisation
des ordinateurs peuvent permettre
d'étendre la portée des sonars comme on
a étendu la portée des radars c'est à
dire que du jour au lendemain les
sous-marins ne serait plus invulnérable
que l' équilibre des forces entre les
deux grands serait remis en question que
la course aux armements reprendre et
caetera et ses savants demande que aux
conversations sur la limitation des
armements stratégiques
eh bien on gèle aussi les recherches qui
en déséquilibrant le potentiel des
forces risquerait donc de relancer la
course aux armements
peut-être même de remettre en cause la
paix mondiale voyez une recherche
fondamentale
apparemment sans conséquence et pourtant
des répercussions qui peuvent être
terribles c'est tout le problème de la
science mais france est close et vous
avez parlé de l'international des
savants est-ce que l'existant vraiment
parce qu'on a un peu tendance à le
prendre pour un mythe
vous savez la science est la même pour
tous et les savants s'en sont rendu
compte et le mouvement de plus qu'aux
achètent quand même très efficace et a
eu même des interventions politiques
efficaces et une intervention
internationale qui réunit des savants de
tous les pays de l'est et de l'ouest et
d'une façon purement individuelle or si
vous voulez apprendre conclure des
nouvelles tout de même de lunas est son
retour dans le kazakhstan les
soviétiques ont calculé sa trajectoire
c'est pour demain à 8 et 6 heures 20 du
matin
alors rendez vous demain à 13h le rap un
peu plus de lune sur la terre avant des
palais des sports avec patrick chapuis
je voudrais vous lire le texte du
premier communiqué publié par le
gouvernement français à l'issue du
conseil des ministres sur la situation
en jordanie
le voici à l'issue du procès des
ministres le gouvernement français a
affirmé tous les efforts menés par
certains gouvernements arabes pour
mettre fin au conflit doivent être
appuyées et aucune intervention
extérieure ne doit se produire sous
peine de créer un risque extrêmement
grave pour la paix mondiale
ce qui confirme donc ce qu'on savait
depuis lundi la france est formellement
opposé à toute intervention étrangère
dans le confit jordanie patrick chapuis
bien que continuant son tour de france
sur échappe au look et le tour de france
automobile et le matra sont toujours en
tête devant la porsche général à rougir
la housse le vainqueur de l'an dernier
est actuellement à 14 minutes
hier soir les pilotes étaient sur le
circuit bugatti c'est un reportage
autres stations du moment la nuit
dernière au mans sur le bugatti les
concurrents du tour de france automobile
divisés en quatre groupes disputer une
épreuve de vitesse sur syrte qu'ils
avaient 30 tours à couvrir soit 132 km
600 soit si le premier groupe celui des
tourismes de série qui avait pris la
piste à 19h été remporté par l'équipe à
levier bolt armand sur opel commode sur
ces images
henri pescarolo et sa matra simca dans
le stand de ravitaillement
il est avec jean pierre beltoise le
grand favori de ce 15e tour de france
automobile
le groupe tourisme spéciales qui avaient
pris le départ vers 21h été remportée
comme on s'y attendait parade nautique
sur belle commode dans la troisième
catégorie les grand tourisme ligne et
herrera sur leur porsche 911s s'était
imposé aisément en réalisant
l'excellente moyenne 227 km jean pierre
beltoise ajuste ses gants dans quelques
secondes il prendra la piste
vingt voitures sur la ligne dans ce
groupe k et bien sûr tous les leaders en
dehors de beltoise et pescarolo larousse
bien sûr chasseuil jacquemin et alten
sur sa ford capri c'est un nouveau venu
dans ce groupe 4
hier les organisateurs avaient en effet
décidé de le faire courir avec les
prototypes et cela n'allait pas lui
porter chance puisque après deux tours
seulement il sera éliminé sur ennui
mécanique il regagnera son stand acquis
à part cette élimination daltonienne pas
de surprise hier soir les deux matra
toujours en tête
en troisième position la roue 104e
chasseuil en 5e japon vers 2 heures du
matin les derniers concurrents
reprenaient la route direction rouen où
se disputera ce soir une autre épreuve
de vitesse
la grosse bonne surprise reste même le
comportement de ces deux matra qui avait
été conçu pour courir aux 24 heures du
mans donc sur une piste et non pas sur
les 5000 km2 nationales et
départementales de cette épreuve
autour de la chance d'y retrouvailles en
poule b celle des brésiliens et des
anglais qui ont joué un match à new york
vous allez voir bobby moore et pelé qui
a marqué les deux buts brésiliens les
deux équipes ont fait match nul 2 à 2 en
france c'est la 8e journée du
championnat de france le leader rennes
joue chez lui ce soir contre strasbourg
strasbourg qui pourra enfin utiliser les
services de sa nouvelle vedette
yougoslave qui s'appelle ivan osm par ce
beau temps la baie de quiberon
maintenant est devenu véritable paradis
de la voile nous avons vu la semaine
dernière les championnats de france
voici maintenant les championnats du
monde chocolat du monde de la série des
temps peste le temps peste est un
quillard abattoirs qui y à deux
équipiers
c'est un bateau qui est une nouvelle
série olympique les équipages américains
font la loi en ce moment au championnat
du monde des tempêtes qui se déroule
rapport à ligue 1 dans le magnifique
plan d'eau de la baie de quiberon
après les deux premières manches sur les
cinq inscrits au total les américains se
sont emparés des premières places à
l'équipage est venu troubler cette
hégémonie
les hollandais stats pièce pires coque
vainqueur de la seconde manche et 3e au
classement général
que deviennent les français leurs
chances paraissent particulièrement
modestes dans ce concert international
group est là les verts sont en 11e
position au général sur 46 classes et la
lutte au sommet demeure cependant serrés
ainsi si star pièce a remporté la
victoire
line ville nesbitt a et foster était
présent hier à exploiter la moindre
faille technique
quoi qu'il en soit il sera
particulièrement difficile de relever le
défi des hommes d'outre-atlantique
les hollandais et les britanniques ainsi
que le soviétique mannequine ex champion
olympique sur finn paraissant bien trop
isolé pour opposer une résistance
organisée à leurs adversaires au cours
de la troisième manche qui se déroule
aujourd'hui
aussi parlé des coupes de l'america vod
américain est là aussi pour la loi
d'ailleurs oui ils font la loi ils ont
maintenant une avance qui est peut-être
décisif puisqu'ils ont remporté leur
troisième victoire consécutive vous
voyez ici intrépide à trépident dont
l'équipage est déjà sur le pont la
victoire remportée derrière gretel qui
n'était pas loin
à une minute seulement et 18 secondes
maintenant avec trois victoires je pense
que c'est fini vous savez qu'il faut
remporter quatre victoires pour avoir la
coupe de l'america les américains vont
apporter leur 21e succès consécutif dans
cette épreuve et ils sont vraiment très
forts quoi pour la triste france n'est
ce pas avec votre invité un autre genre
de sport sans danger le billard
électrique
j'ai cru aussi est là quand c'est ce que
la flip poste voulait dire le billard
électrique mais j'ai tout de suite
demandé à philippe wolff qui est
l'auteur de ce titre un peu insolite
justement de vous expliquer pourquoi il
a choisi ce titre plie peser qu'est ce
qu'il a voulu dire pas plus que ceux se
veut dire ça vient d'un mot qui fait
flipper flipper c'est dans un certain
art beau ça veut dire perdre la tête par
les pédales peut dire que c'est jouer au
billard électrique dans sa tête
oui je crois que ça rejoint assez bien
la démarche de l'héroïne puisque
l'héroïne dont nous ne savons jamais le
nom ça c'est pas du tout gênant et
voudrais vous demander qui est cette
dame qui est si peu ce qui se nomme
chine dame très seul c'est ça son
principal problème
elle est jeune elle a 26 27 ans elle est
mariée elle a une petite fille elle a
des amis mais elle est très seule allée
chez elle ne fait rien elle s'ennuie
elle s'ennuie et elle devient peu folle
ça je compte dans votre livre dans votre
livre il ya philippe wolff et
critique un peu sournoise d'une certaine
société de consommation je voudrais vous
demander comment vous est venu vous à
décrire ce climat et à placer votre
héroïne dans ce climat justin mon
héroïne est venue d'un certain malaise
que je ressemblais parce que je
travaille dans la publicité sur
rédacteur publicitaire et je passe mon
temps à penser à une certaine femme qui
est la consommatrice moyenne goudé et un
jour j'ai eu un peu honte quand même de
cette recherche
j'ai essayé de prendre une femme qui est
ce consommatrices moyenne est de mettre
dans une certaine situation et de voir
comment elle allait réagir et là dans
mon livre elle réagit assez mal
puisqu'elle elle se crée un un monde à
elle un monde où elle tue énormément sa
manière le révolté contre entourage
qu'elle ne comprend pas et menez et
philippe sans aller jusqu à ces extrêmes
évidemment le comportement traduit par
un malaise social créé ce prêt qui
revient est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
une femme qui peut vivre disons dans
n'importe quelle ville de france enfin
j'entends ou alençon où monte carlo
sinon paris même je crois que je crois
que ça se passe là paris mais refait
surface elle vous pensez que c'est une
femme une consommatrice moyenne qui peut
avoir ce type de crise soient les passes
quand même un peu la moyenne
je crois ce que je voudrais justement
précisé que ce livre qui s'appelle donc
la friteuse qui est paru aux éditions
denoël et je crois on peut le dire
finalement un livre très drôle sur
l'ennui parce que ça quelque chose de
grand sens da c'est horrible
débrouillez très bien dans cette espèce
d'humour noir et votre héroïne est une
femme qui a de l'humour alors je
rappelle donc la friteuse par philippe
wolff aux éditions denoël avant de
passer la parole à la bourse de paris je
voudrais que michèle dard dit regarde
elle est où des photos que nous venons
de recevoir de copenhague copenhague où
cette nuit il ya encore eu des
manifestations contre la réunion dans la
ville du fonds monétaire international
et des manifestations qui ont été
particulièrement violentes vous savez
que ces jeunes gens reprochent aux
délégués du fonds monétaire
internationale d'accorder une aide trop
importante à des pays riches comme
l'afrique du sud ou la rhodésie alors
distille que d'autres pays en ont
beaucoup plus besoin
pour en revenir à la bourse je pense
michel tardieu qu'elle a été très
favorablement impressionné par l'arrivée
aujourd'hui en france en visite
officielle du premier ministre de
singapour monsieur lee kuan yew et là je
crois
cela mérite une explication ont
favorablement impressionné c'est
beaucoup dire je ne suis pas sûr que
beaucoup de boursiers soient au courant
c'est arrivé de monsieur lee kuan yew
mais ce qui est bien intéressant dans
singapour c'est que cette petite île que
tout le monde connaît qui est situé au
bout de la péninsule de malacca au sud
de la malaisie
pas très loin de sumatra a opté d'une
façon tout à fait définitive pour le
capitalisme et de la part d'un pays qui
sait des colonisés il n'y a pas très
longtemps il ya onze ans je crois et
bien c'est à fait assez exceptionnel
et cette option pour le capitalisme a
fort bien marché ce qui peut donc faire
plaisir à tous les financiers et à tous
les gens qui sont pour l'économie
libérale ce qui est bien sûr le cas des
boursiers et si vous voulez pendant que
les cours vont défiler je vous dis tout
de suite que la bourse n'est pas très
bonne nous sommes pour le premier jour
pour le premier jour du terme
ce n'est pas une très bonne séance on
est simplement résistant avec quelques
roses quand même assez considérable
celles de citroën de russel est
petrofina que vous verrez sur les
tableaux pendant qu'ils vont défiler et
je retourne à singapour pour dire que
monsieur lee a effectivement accueilli
et protégé les capitaux étrangers d'une
façon tout à fait vigilante qu'il a
supprimé les retenue qui existait sur
les intérêts servis précisément vous
capitaux étrangers qui l'a supprimé
également les restrictions à la liberté
des changes qu'il a garanti le secret
bancaire voyait tout série de choses
dont les financiers du monde entier sont
très friands et cette politique
totalement différente de celle qu'ont
adopté la plupart des ex colonies
françaises a porté ses fruits
singapour est devenue une place
financière importante et elle a
également cette politique facilité
l'industrialisation du pays
et pour montrer sans ambiguïté à quel
point il se méfie l'étatisation monsieur
lee a créé récemment une banque de
développement est un organisme semi
public mais il est contrôlé à 51% par
des capitaux privés et 30 et 40 9%
seulement pour l'état c'est tout à fait
remarquable parce que en général quand
des fonctionnaires d'un pays quelconque
est particulièrement occidentales
peuvent s'assurer le contrôle d'une
banque en prenant simplement 2% du
capital
eh bien ils n'hésitent pas à le faire ça
n'a pas été le cas à singapour le pays
connaît une prospérité qui est
exceptionnel dans cette partie du monde
si bien que les américains l'appellent
la suisse de l'extrême orient
en tout cas le dollar de singapour va
bien et à copenhague où les experts du
fmi continue de travailler et où les
manifestants vous venez de le voir
continuer de manifester
eh bien on parlera sûrement beaucoup
moins du dollar de singapour que du
dollar américain
pour l'instant autant qu'on puisse en
juger les américains et suis plutôt un
semi échec à copenhague
en effet il semble acquis que les
solutions qui se rapportait au taux de
change flottants ne seront pas adoptés
et que monsieur giscard d'estaing qui
lui défend des au contraire une certaine
autonomie si mon stand orthodoxie
monétaire pardon propre porte
un succès s'il y a des possibilités
accrues pour les changes
eh bien elles sont quand même assez
limité et on augmentera peut-être
simplement les marges de fluctuation
autorisé ce qui serait assez conforme à
ce que souhaitait la délégation
française
ce maintien d'une certaine orthodoxie
devrait avoir pour première conséquence
de décourager à ce nombre de
spéculateurs sur les monnaies peut-être
que ces spéculateurs reviendront en
bourse en tout cas il serait bien
nécessaire qu'ils
parce que pour l'instant quand même le
marché de paris manque d'initiative on
se demande quelles sont les informations
qui pourraient redonner un peu de moral
aux boursiers et il faut dire aussi
qu'on les comprend tant que le
moyen-orient est ce qu'il est hier les
présidents de pechiney et d'ugine
kullmann ont confirmé ce que nous avions
dit dès la 10 concernant la fusion des
deux sociétés au cours de leur
conférence de presse
et surtout après on a entendu beaucoup
de pignon sur ce mariage et dans tout
mariage il y a des commères qui papote
et ses commentaires déco mais allait de
l'affirmation que cette fusion n'avait
pas de raison logique qu'elle ne servait
à rien jusqu'à eu d'admiration béate
devant ce groupe énorme qui sera le
premier probablement de l'industrie
française sans prétendre trancher dans
ce débat je crois qu'on peut faire
plusieurs remarques
la première c'est que la force a
toujours été un bon atout pour une
société industrielle
les grands sont toujours nous accueillit
notamment à l'étranger et donc sa force
nouvelle permettra au nouveau groupe de
s'implanter sur les sources
d'approvisionnement en minerais
s'implanter à l'étranger que ce soit
pour la bauxite pour faire de
l'aluminium que ce soit pour le cuivre
ou pour le nickel donc c'est un premier
point important le second c'est que
pechiney qui ne fait pour l'instant que
dans celui de l'aluminium se rend compte
que dans le monde entier on installe
beaucoup d' usine nouvelle pour
fabriquer l'aluminium et que finalement
dans quelques années dans un avenir plus
ou moins lointain il pouvait y avoir une
certaine surproduction ce n'est pas
encore un danger très menaçants mais il
est bon quand même pour une société
comme pechiney d'avoir plusieurs cordes
à son arc
voilà je crois ce qu'on peut retenir ses
conférences de presse d'hier ici la
bourse de paris avoue alain cancer avant
de conclure ce journal je voudrais vous
rappeler l'essentiel du communiqué
publié à paris à l'issue du conseil des
ministres français la france est
formellement opposé à toute intervention
étrangère dans le conflit jordanien et
puis on a deux minutes des rumeurs
circulent pas tel aviv des rumeurs selon
lesquelles les troupes syriennes
auraient commencé à se retirer de
jordanie je voulais dit ce sont des
rumeurs il faut donc attendre
confirmation mais il est bien certain
que si les troupes syriennes se retirait
de jordanie une évolution très nette se
produirait très vite dans ce pays
voilà notre journal est terminée bon
après midi